[Music]
now that intend to switch presentation
is over it seems like we're learning
more about the system's games every
minute this time we've learned the
resolution and framerate of Mario Kart 8
deluxe from the company's treehouse
livestream I'm Matt and this is your
frame counting GameSpot news update
Nintendo has confirmed that Mario Kart 8
deluxe will run at 1080p and 60 frames
per second on the switch information
from neogaf says that the frame rate
drops to 30 frames per second when there
are more than two players racing however
when you take it on the go the
resolution decreases to 720p which is
the maximum resolution of the switches
tablet like screen unfortunately we
don't know if the frame rate remains
unchanged when going from the TV to the
tablet Mario Kart 8 deluxe comes with
all the tracks and characters from the
Wii U version but introduces new
characters kingboo dry bones and Bowser
jr. in addition to inkling girl and
inkling boy from the splatoon series it
also features the ability to carry two
items at once and a new battle mode that
adds new courses and game types for more
news about the switch and the world of
video games stay tuned to game spots